The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
Thank you for showing
up to this very
special pre-Thanksgiving
lecture.
I'm glad you guys have
such devotion to security,
I'm sure that you will be
rewarded on the job market
at some point.
Feel free to list me
as a recommendation.
So today we're going to
talk about taint tracking,
and in particular we're going
to look at a system called
TaintDroid that looks at how
to do this type of information
flow analysis in the context
of Android smartphones.
And so the basic problem
the paper deals with
is this fact that apps
can exfiltrate data.
So the basic idea
is that your phone
contains a lot of sensitive
information, right.
It contains your contacts
list and your phone number
and your email and all
that kind of stuff.
So if the operating system or
the phone itself isn't careful,
then a malicious app
might be able to take
some of that information
and send it back
to its home server,
and that server
can use it for all types
of nefarious things
as we'll talk about later.
The high-level solution that
the TaintDroid paper suggests
is that we should basically
track the sensitive data as it
flows through the system,
and essentially, we
need to stop it from
going over the network.
In other words,
we need to stop it
from being passed as an argument
to networking system calls.
And so presumably,
if we can do that,
then we can essentially stop
the leak right at the moment
that it's about to happen.
So you might think
to yourself, so why
are traditional
Android permissions
insufficient to stop these
types of data exfiltrations?
And the reason is that these
permissions don't really
have the appropriate grammar to
talk about the type of attack
that we're trying to prevent.
So a lot of times these
Android permissions,
they deal with these things
like can an application
read or write to a
particular device.
But we're talking
about something
at a sort of different
level of semantics.
We're saying even if an
application has been granted
the authority to read or
write a particular device,
like the network,
for example, it still
might not be good to allow that
application to read or write
certain sensitive data over
that device to which it
has permissions.
In other words, using these
traditional Android security
policies, it is
difficult to speak
about specific types of data.
It's much easier to talk about
whether an application accesses
a device or not.
So you might think, all right,
so that's kind of a bummer,
but maybe we can
solve this problem
by-- we have this alternate
solution, so we'll
call this solution star.
So maybe we can
just never install
applications that can do
reads of sensitive data
and also have network access.
At first glance, that
seems to solve the problem.
Because if it can't do
both of these things,
it either can't get
to the sensitive data
in the first place, or it can,
but it can't send it anywhere.
So does anyone have any ideas
where this probably isn't
going to work out very well?
Everyone's already
thinking about turkey.
I can see in your eyes.
The main reason why this
is probably a bad idea
is that this is going to break a
lot of legitimate applications.
So you could imagine that
there are a lot of programs,
like maybe email
clients or things
like that, that should actually
have the ability, perhaps,
to read some data
that's sensitive
and also send information
over the network.
So if we just say
that we're going
to prevent this sort of
and type of activity,
then you're actually going
to make a lot of things
that work right now fail.
So users are not
going to like that.
There's also a problem here is
that even if we did implement
this solution, it's not going to
stop a bunch of different side
channel mechanisms
for data leakage.
So for example, we've
looked in previous classes
about how the browser
cache, for example,
can leak information about
whether a particular site has
been visited or not.
And so even if we have a
security policy like this,
maybe we don't capture all
kinds of side channels.
We'll talk about some other
side channels a little later
in the lecture.
Another thing that this
wouldn't stop is app collusion.
So two apps can
actually collaborate
to break the security system.
So for example, what
if there's one app that
doesn't have access
network, but it
can talk to a second
application, which does.
So maybe it can use
Android's IPC mechanisms
to pass the sensitive data
to an application that
does have network permissions,
and that second app can
actually upload that
information to the server.
And even if the apps
aren't colluding,
then there may be
some type of trickery
that an application
can engage in
to trick some other applications
into accidentally revealing
sensitive data.
So maybe there's some type
of weakness in the way
that the email
program is written,
and so perhaps that
email program accepts
too many random messages
from other things that
are living on the system.
So perhaps we could craft a
special intent that's somehow
going to trick your Gmail
application, for example,
into emailing something to
someone outside of the phone.
At a high level, this approach
doesn't really work very well.
One important thing
to think about is OK,
so it seems like we're very
worried about the sensitive
data leaving the phone.
So what does Android malware
actually do in practice.
Are there any kinds
of real world attacks
that we're going to
be preventing by all
this taint tracking type stuff.
And the answer is yes.
So increasingly, malware is
becoming a bigger problem
for these mobile phones.
So one thing it might do is
it might use your location
or maybe your IMEI for ads.
So similarly to
malware, it's actually
going to look and see where
you are physically located
in the world and then maybe
it will that oh, you're
located near the MIT
campus, therefore you
must be a hungry student
so hey, why don't you
go to my food truck that
happens to be located right
where you are.
IMEI is kind of
like this-- you can
think of it as an integer that's
like a per device uniquefier.
So this could be used perhaps
to track you in ways that you
don't want to be tracked,
in different locations,
so on and so forth.
So there's actually
malware in the wild
that does things like that.
Another thing that
malware might try to do
is steal your credentials.
So for example, it might try
to take your phone number,
or it might try to
take your contact list,
it might try to upload those
things to a remote server.
Maybe that's useful for
trying to impersonate you,
for example, in a
message that's going
to be used for spam later on.
There's malware out there that
does things like this today.
Perhaps most horrifyingly,
at least for me,
malware might be able to
turn your phone into a bot.
This, of course, is a problem
that our parents did not
have to deal with.
Modern phones are so powerful
that they can actually
be used to send out spam
messages themselves.
So there's actually
a pretty nasty piece
of malware that's
going around right now
that seems to be targeting some
corporate environments that's
doing precisely this.
So it gets to your phone and
just starts sending out stuff.
AUDIENCE: So this
type of malware,
is it malware that subverts
the Android OS, or is it
just a typical app?
If it's a typical app, it
seems that it should be able--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a good question.
There's both types
of malware out there.
As it turns out, it's
actually fairly easy
to get users to click on things.
So I'll give you an example.
This isn't necessarily
indicative of malware,
more about the sad
state of humanity.
There'll be a popular
game out there,
let's say Angry
Birds, for example.
You go to the App Store and
you type in Angry Birds,
I want to get Angry Birds.
So hopefully the
first hit that you get
is the actual Angry Birds.
But then the second hit will
be something like Angry Birdss,
with two S's, for example.
And a lot of people
will go there,
and maybe it's cheaper
than the regular version,
and they go there.
It's going to present
that thing that says,
do you allow this application
to do this, this, and this.
The person is going say, yeah,
because I got to get my Angry
Birds, yeah, sure.
Boom, then that
person could be owned.
So in practice you
see now where it
exploits both types of vectors.
But you're exactly right that
if you assume that the Android
security model is correct,
then the malware sort
has to depend on users
being foolish or naive
and giving it network
access, for example,
when your tic-tac-toe
game shouldn't really
have network access.
Yes, so you can
actually have your phone
get turned into a bot.
This is horrible for
multiple reasons,
not only because
your phone is a bot
but also because
maybe you're paying
for data for all
those emails that are
getting sent from your phone.
Maybe your battery's
getting ground down
because you phone's just
sitting around constantly
sending ads about whenever, free
trips to Bermuda or whatever.
There are actually malicious
applications out there
that will use your private
information for bad.
And the particularly
bad thing about this bot
here is that it can actually
look at your contact
list and some spam
on your behalf
to people that you know and make
the likelihood of the victim
clicking on something in
that email much, much higher.
One thing to note, and
this kind of getting back
to the discussion
we just had, so
preventing this
data exfiltration
is very nice, right.
But in and of itself,
preventing that exfiltration
doesn't stop the hack
in the first place.
So there's actually
mechanisms that we actually
should look at to prevent your
machine from getting owned
in the first place or to
educate users about what they
should and should not click on.
So just doing this
taint tracking
isn't a full solution for
preventing your machine
from getting compromised.
How is TaintDroid in
particular going to work?
Let's see.
So as I mentioned
before, TaintDroid
is going to track all of
your sensitive information
as it propagates
through the system.
So TaintDroid
distinguishes between what
they call information sources
and information sinks.
So these sources are things
that generate sensitive data.
So you might think of this
as things like sensors.
So for example,
GPS, accelerometer,
things like that.
This could be your
contact list database,
this could be things like the
IMEI, basically anything that
might help to tie you,
a particular user,
to your actual phone.
So these are the things
that generate the taint.
And then you can
think of these sinks
as being the places where we
don't want tainted data to go.
And so in the case
of TaintDroid,
the particular sink that we're
concerned about is the network.
As we'll talk about later, you
can generalize information flow
to more scenarios than
TaintDroid specifically covers.
So you can imagine there
might be other sinks in a more
general purpose system.
But for TaintDroid,
they're literally
caring about the network as
the sink for information.
So in TaintDroid, they're
going to use a 32-bit bitvector
to represent taint.
And so what this basically
means is that you can have,
at most, 32 distinct
taint sources.
So each sensitive
data value will
have a one in a
particular position
if it has been tainted by some
particular source of taint.
That's like, has it been
derived from your GPS data,
for example.
Has it been derived from
something from your contacts
list, and so on and so forth.
One interesting thing is
that 32 sources of taint
is actually not that big, right.
And so an interesting
question is,
is that big enough for
this particular system
and is it big enough in
general for these information
flow systems.
So in a particular
case of TaintDroid,
32 possible sources
of taint seems
to be somewhat reasonable,
because it's actually
looking at a fairly constrained
information flow problem.
So it's saying given all the
sensors you have on your phone,
given all of these
sensitive databases,
and things like that,
32 seems roughly
the right order of
magnitude in terms
of storing these taint flags.
And as we'll see in the
implementation of this system,
32 is actually very
convenient, too,
because what else is 32 bits?
Well, an integer.
So you can actually do some
very efficient representations
of these taint flags in the way
that they actually build this.
As we'll discuss a
little bit later,
though, if you want to expose
information flow to programmers
in a more generic
way, so for example,
if you want programmers
be able to specify
their own sources of taint
and their own types of sink,
then 32 bits probably
isn't enough.
In systems like
that you actually
have to think about including
more complex runtime support
for a larger label space.
So does that all make sense?
OK so roughly speaking,
when you look at the way
that a taint flows through
the system, at a high level,
it basically goes from the
right hand side of a statement
to the left hand side.
So as a very simple example,
if you had some statement,
like you declare an integer
variable that's going to get
your latitude, and then a high
level you call gps.getLat(),
then essentially this thing here
is going to generate a value
that has some taint
that's associated with it.
Some particular flag will
be set that indicates
that hey, this
value I'm returning
comes from a sensitive source.
So the taint will come from
here on the right hand side
and go over here to
the left hand side,
and now that is
actually tainted.
So that's sort of what it
looks like from the perspective
of the human developer
who writes source code.
However, the Dalvik VM actually
uses this register-based format
at the lower level to
actually build programs,
and that's actually the way
that these taint semantics
are implemented in reality.
This is what's explained
in table one of the papers,
so they have this big list
of classes of opcodes,
and they describe how
taint sort of flows
for those types of opcodes.
So for example,
you might imagine
that you have an operation
that looks kind of like a move,
and so it mentions a
destination and a source.
So in Dalvik, to register
a base virtual machines,
so you can think
of these as being
registers on this sort of
abstract computation engine.
And so essentially what happens
here is that, like I said,
taint goes from the right hand
side to the left hand side.
So in this case, when
the Dalvik interpreter
executes this
instruction here, it's
going to look at the
taint label, this,
and it's going to
assign it over here.
Then you might imagine you
have another instruction that's
like a binary operation.
So think of this as something
like addition, for example.
So here you'll have
a single destination,
but then you'll
have two sources.
And what will
happen in this case
is that when Dalvik interpreter
encounters this instruction,
it'll take the taints
of both of these,
construct a union of those,
and then assign that union
to be the taint tag over here.
Does that all make sense?
It's fairly straightforward.
So the table breaks down all the
different types of instructions
that you'll see, but to
a first approximation,
these are the most
common ways that taint
propagates through the system.
Now there are actually some
interesting special cases
that they mention in the paper.
So one of those special
cases involves arrays.
Let's say that you
have some code that's
going to declare a
character, and you
get the value for the character
somehow, doesn't really matter.
And then let's say the
program declares some array,
we'll call it upper().
And it's basically going to have
uppercase versions of letters.
And so one very common
thing to do in code
is to index into an array like
this using, for example, maybe
just C directly,
because as we all know,
Kernighan and Ritchie teach us
that basically characters are
integers, so hooray for that.
So you can imagine that
you have some code that
says something like the upper
case version of this character
here is going to be whatever
is at a particular index
in this table here, in the
index that table by c like this.
So there's a question of what
taint should this receive.
It seems pretty
straightforward what
should happen in these
cases, but in this case,
it seems like we have multiple
things that are going on.
We've got this array here that
may have some type of taint,
we've got this character
c here that may
have some type of taint.
What Dalvik decides
to do in this case
is a little bit
similar to what it
does in the case of
this binary op here.
So it's essentially going to say
that this character over here
is going to get the union
of the taint of c and also
of the array.
And the intuition behind
that is that to generate
this character, we somehow
had to know something
about this array here.
We had to know something
about this index here.
So therefore I
guess it makes sense
that this thing should
be as sensitive as both
of these things combined.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
again move op and binary
op, what exactly it means,
like the union of a taint.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so
imagine that-- let's look
at the move op here.
So imagine that this
source operation here just
had-- actually, let
me get more concrete.
So each variable,
as I'll described
in a second what a variable is,
has this integer, essentially,
that has a bunch of
bits that are set
according to what taint it has.
So imagine each one of
these values flying around
has this associated
integer flying
around that has some bits set.
So let's say that this source
had two bits set, corresponding
to the fact that it had
been tainted by two things,
it doesn't really matter.
So what the interpreter will do
is it will look at this source
thing, it'll look at
the associated integer,
and it'll say aha.
I should take that integer
has those two bits set
and then essentially make that
integer the taint tag for this.
So that's sort of a
simple case, right.
The more complicated case,
like what does the union
actually look like.
So imagine that we've
got these two things here
and we've got
source 0, source 1.
And so I'm going
to show you here,
these are the tainted
bits for this particular--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
imagine that you have
this is the taint for this one.
And imagine that the taint
for this one is this.
So what's the taint going
to look like for dest?
You basically take
all of the bits that
are saying either one of
those and then assign that
to that throwback to this one.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no problem.
And so one reasons, so once
again I should emphasize this,
so since we can represent all
the possible taints in this 32
bits, as we were
just discussing,
doing this operation here,
it's just bitwise operations.
So this actually really
cuts down on the overhead
from implementing
these taint bits.
If you had to express a
larger universe of taints then
you might be in trouble,
because you might not
be able to use these
very efficient bitwise
operations to do things.
Any other questions about that?
OK.
So the way that arrays work is
a little bit like that binary op
like I mentioned.
So this is going
to get the union
of the taint of this and that.
And so one design decision
that they made in TaintDroid
is that they associate a single
taint tab with each array.
So in other words,
they're not going
to try to taint all the
individual elements in there.
So basically what's
going to end up
happening is that this is going
to save them storage space,
right, because for each
array they declare,
they'll just have a
single through route
to the entity that sort of
floats around that array
and represents all the taint
that belongs to that array.
There is one
question about why is
it safe to not have a finer
grain system for taint.
Because it seems like an
array is a collection of data,
so why shouldn't we have a
bunch of labels flying around
for each thing
that's in that array?
And so the answer to
that is that by only
associating one taint
tag with the array
and making it the union of
all the things that's inside,
that actually is going
to overestimate taint.
So in other words, if
you have an array that
has two items in
it, and that array
is tainted with the union
of all of those things,
well, that's probably a little
bit-- it's conservative.
Because it may be that if
something only accesses this,
maybe it didn't learn
anything about the taint
that was over here.
But by being
conservative, hopefully we
will always be correct.
In other words, if
we underestimate
the amount of taint
that something had,
then we might accidentally
disclose something
that we didn't want
to actually disclose.
But if we overestimate,
then in the worst case,
maybe we prevent something from
going outside of the phone that
should actually
OK, but we're going
to be err on the side of safety.
Does that all makes sense?
Another instance of-- a
sort of special case taint
propagation that they mention
are things like native methods.
And so native methods
might exist inside of the v
in itself, so for example, the
Dalvik VM exposes some function
like a System.arraycopy(), so
we can pass in anything through
this, and internal to the VM,
this is implemented in C or C++
code for reasons of speed.
That's one type of example of
a native method you might have.
Another thing you might
have, a type of native method
is what they call
JNI expose methods.
So the native
interface essentially
allows Java code
to call into code
that is not Java, that's
implemented using x86 or ARM
or something like that.
There's a whole
calling convention
that's exposed here to allow
those two types of stacks
to interoperate.
And so the problem with
these native code methods,
from the perspective
of tracking taint,
is that this native code is
not being executed directly
by the Dalvik interpreter.
In fact, it is often not even
Java code, maybe C or C++ code.
So that means that once
execution flow goes
into one of these
native methods,
TaintDroid can't do any
of this taint propagation
that it's doing for code
that lives in the Java world.
So that seems a
little bit problematic
because these things are
kind of like black boxes.
You want to make sure that
when these methods return,
we can actually
somehow represent
the new taint that was
created by the execution
of those methods.
And so the way that the
authors solve this issue is,
they essentially result
to manual analysis.
So they basically say,
there are not a whole lot
of these types of methods here.
So for example, the Dalvik VM
only exposes a certain number
of functions like
Systems.arraycopy(),
so we as human developers can
look through this relatively
small number of calls and
essentially figure out what
the taint relationship
should be.
So for example, they can look
at something like array copy
and say, OK, based
on what we know
the semantics of
this operation are,
we know that we should
taint the return values
from this function
in a certain way
given the input values
to this function.
And so how well does this scale?
Well, if there are in
fact only a small number
of things exposed by, for
example, the VM in native code,
this actually works OK.
Because if you assume that the
Dalvik VM interface doesn't
change very often,
then it's actually not
too burdensome to look at these
things, view the documentation,
and figure out how
taint's going to spread.
This may or may not
be more troublesome.
They give some empirical
data that suggests that a lot
of applications
are not, in fact,
including code alongside of
them that's actually going
to execute in C or C++.
So they argued that
empirically, this is not
going to be a big problem.
They also argue that for certain
types of method signatures,
you can actually automate
the way in which these taint
calculations are done.
So they say that, for example,
if only integers or strings are
pass in to some of these
native functions here, then
we can just do the standard
thing of tagging the output
value with the union of all
things the taints of the input.
So in practice, it seems
like this isn't probably
going to be too big
of a problem here.
AUDIENCE: But why couldn't
you just scan-- whatever
scans your code [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah, so in
practice, what do they do.
So they know that whenever the
interpreter is going to execute
something like this, then when
the return value comes back,
they do have special case code
that's going to automagically
say return values of
System.arraycopy() should have
this taint assigned to it.
AUDIENCE: Right, so what's
the manual part of it?
PROFESSOR: Oh, the
manual part of it
is figuring out what that policy
should be in the first place.
So in other words, if you
just look at off the shelf
Taint or off the
shelf Android, this
is going to do
something for you,
but it's not going to
automatically assign
Taint in the right way.
So someone looks
at this and figures
out what that policy is.
Make sense?
Any other questions?
It doesn't look
like this is going
to be a big problem in practice,
although you can imagine that,
for example, if there
was this increasing
amount of applications that
define these native outcalls,
then we could be in a
little bit of a problem.
All right.
So another type of
data that we have
to worry about assigning
taint to, IPC messages.
And so IPC messages
are essentially
treated like arrays.
So each one of these
messages is going
to be associated with
a single taint that
is the union of the taint of
all the constituent parts.
Once again, this
helps with efficiency
because we only have
to store one taint tag
for each one of these messages.
And in the worst case,
this is conservative,
it overestimates taint.
But that should never
result in a security leak.
At worst, it should
only result in something
that should have been able to
go over the network not being
able to go on the network.
This is how things work
when you're constructing
the message, so
that message gets
the union of all the
taint of its components.
Then when you're
reading it, what you
receive in the message--
so extracted data
gets the taint of the message
itself, which makes sense.
So that's how IPC
messages are treated.
Another resource you might worry
about is how a file's handled.
So once again each file
gets a single taint tag,
and that tag is
essentially stored
alongside the file in its
metadata on stable stores
like the SD card or whatever.
So this is basically the
same conservative scheme
that we've seen before.
So the basic idea is that
the application accesses
some sensitive data like,
for example, your GPS
location, maybe it's going
to write that data to a file.
So TaintDroid updates
that file's taint tag
with the GPS flag, maybe
the application closes down,
later on some other application
comes out, it reads that file.
When it comes into the
VM, into the application,
TaintDroid will
look and see that it
has that flag marked,
and so any data that's
derived from reading that file
will also have that GPS flag
set.
So pretty
straightforward, I think.
So what kind of
things do we have
to taint in terms of Java State.
So there's basically five
types of Java objects
that need taint flags.
And so the first kind of
thing is local variables
that live in a method.
So we can imagine
back over here,
this is a local variable,
char c, for example.
So we have to assign taint
flags to those things.
You can also imagine
that method arguments
need to have taint flags.
Both of these things here,
these live in a stack.
So a TaintDroid has to keep
track of assigning flags
and whatnot for those
types of things.
Also we need to assign flags
to object instance fields.
And so this is like, imagine
that I have some object called
c, it's a circle so of
course the proper thing to do
is I want to look at its radius.
Here's a field here.
And so we have to associate
taint information for each one
of these fields here.
Java also allows you to
have a static class field,
and so you need taint
information for those.
This is saying something like,
for example, maybe the circle
that some property, OK,
we'll assign some taint
information there.
Then arrays, as we've
already discussed before,
we'll assign one piece
of taint information
per that entire array.
And so the basic
idea for how we're
going to store these taint flags
at the implementation level,
is that we're going to try
to basically store the taint
flags for a variable
near the variable itself.
The basic idea here is
we've got, for example,
let's say some integer
variable, and we
want to store some
taint state with that.
We want to try to keep that
state as close to the variable
as possible for reasons
of making the cache
work efficiently at
the processor level.
So if we were to
store taint very far
away from that
variable, that can
be problematic because
probably, the interpreter
is going to look at the memory
value for the actual Java
variable.
It's going to want to very
quickly thereafter, or even
before that, look and see
what the taint information is.
Because if you look at
these operations here,
the same places
in the code where
the interpreter's
looking at the values,
it's also looking at taint.
Basically by storing these
things close to each other,
you try to make the
cache behavior better.
And the way that they
do this is actually
pretty straightforward.
So if you look at what they
do for method arguments
and local variables
that live on a stack,
they essentially
allocate the taint flags
right next to where the
variables are allocated.
So let's say that we have our
favorite thing in this class,
a stack diagram,
which you'll probably
hate after you get out of here.
So you've got some local
variable 0 on the stack,
and then what
TaintDroid will do is
it will store the taint
tag for that variable
right next to where that
local variable is in memory.
So similarly, if you had
another local variable here,
then you would see its
taint tag right down here.
So on and so forth.
Pretty straightforward.
So hopefully you
get these things
in the same cache line, that's
going to make the accesses very
cheap.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering, how can you
have a single flag
for an entire array
and a different flag for
every property of an object.
What if one of the
methods of the object
can access data which is
stored in its properties.
That would like--
know what I mean?
PROFESSOR: Let's see.
So you're asking as
a policy reason, why?
AUDIENCE: As a
policy reason, right.
PROFESSOR: So I think some of
this they do for implementation
efficiency reasons.
I think that for the case--
so they have some other rules,
too.
For example, they say that they
don't say a length of the data
array, is actually going
to leak information,
so they don't propagate
taint for that.
So some of it is just for
reasons of efficiency.
I think that in principle, that
there's nothing that stops you
from saying, take every
element in the array
and, when you do some
particular access on it,
then you just say the thing
on the left hand side's
going to get the
taint, only that items.
It's not completely clear
that's the right thing
to do, though,
because presumably
in getting that thing into
the array in the first place,
the thing that did that
had to know something
about the array in some way.
So I think it's a combination
of both policy reasons--
they think that by being
overly conservative,
you shouldn't allow any data
leaks that you want to prevent.
And also I think that it
kind of does intuitively
make sense that
accessing an array,
you should have to know
something about that array.
And when you have to know
something about something,
that typically means that
you want to get tainted by.
Any other questions?
OK, so this is the
basic scheme that they
use for essentially storing
all of this information close
to each other.
So you can imagine
that for class fields
and for object fields,
you do a similar thing.
So in the declaration
of the class,
you've got some slot memory for
a particular instance variable,
and then right next
to that slot you
have the taint information
for that particular variable.
So I think that's all
pretty reasonable.
That's kind of a high level
overview of how TaintDroid
works, so if you get all
this, then the basic idea
behind TaintDroid is
actually pretty simple.
So at system initialization
time or whatever,
TaintDroid looks at all these
sources of potentially tainted
information, and
essentially assigns a flag
to each one of these things.
So things like your GPS, your
camera, and so on and so forth.
As the program
executes, it's going
to pull out
sensitive information
from these sensitive sources,
and then as that kind of thing
happens, the
interpreter is going
to look at all these
types of op codes
here and basically
follow those policy
rules in the table on
the paper, and figure out
how to propagate taint
through the system.
So the most interesting
part is what
happens if data attempts
to exfiltrate itself.
So essentially, TaintDroid can
sit at the network interfaces
and they can see everything that
tries to go over the network
interface.
We actually look at
the taint tags there
and we can say if data that's
trying to leave the network
has one or more taint
flags, then we will say no.
That data will not be
allowed to go in the network.
Now what happens at
that point is actually
kind of application-dependent.
You could imagine that
TaintDroid shows an alert
to the user which
says hey, somebody's
trying to send your
location over the network.
You could imagine that
maybe TaintDroid has
some policies that are
built in which, for example,
maybe it allows that
network flow to go out,
but it zeros out all
that sensitive data,
so on and so forth.
That's from a certain
perspective, a little bit
orthogonal to the
core contribution
of the paper, which is to
find those data exfiltrations
in the first place.
In the evaluation
section of the paper,
they discuss some of the
things that they found.
They do find that
Android applications will
try to exfiltrate
data in ways that
were not exposed to the user.
So for example, they will
try to use your location
for advertisements, they
will send your phone number
and things like this
to remote servers.
Once again, it's important to
note that these applications,
typically they weren't
breaking the Android security
model in the sense
that the user had
allowed these applications
with access to the network,
for example.
Or they had allowed
these applications
to have access to things
like a contact list.
However, the
applications did not
exposed to the user in the
EULA, in the End User License
Agreement, that hey, I'm going
to take your phone number
and actually send it to
some server in Silk Road 8
or whatever.
That's actually misleading and
deceptive, because most users,
if they'd actually
seen that in the EULA
and they'd known
that was happening,
they might have at least
had a second thought about
whether they want to install
this application or not.
AUDIENCE: Is it reasonable to
guess that even if they put it
in the EULA, that
that's not really worth
it because people
never read those.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it
is, in fact, quite
reasonable to assume that.
So even well trained computer
scientists like myself
do not always check out
the EULA because it's
like, you gotta
have Flappy Birds
or what are you going to do.
I think what is useful,
though, and this
is kind of spiritually
unsatisfying but useful
in practice, is that if
it is put in the EULA,
then maybe there will be
some virtuous individuals who
do actually read the EULA.
AUDIENCE: And they
could tell you like--
PROFESSOR: That's
right, that's right.
AUDIENCE: --don't do that one.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
Consumer Reports
or some moral equivalent will
say our job is to read EULAs,
and by the way, you
shouldn't download this app.
But you're exactly correct
that relying on users
to read pages of tiny
print is basically--
they're not going to do it.
They're going to hit Next
and then keep on going.
OK, so any questions
up to this point?
I think that the rules
for how information
flows through the system
are fairly straightforward.
So as we were discussing,
it's basically
taint from the right hand
side goes to the left side.
Sometimes, though, these
information flow rules
can have somewhat
counterintuitive results.
So imagine that
an application is
going to implement its
own linked list class.
So it's going to define some
simple class up here called
ListNode and it's going to
have an object field for data.
And then it will have
a ListNode object
which represents the next
thing in the linked list.
Suppose if the application
assigned some tainted data
to this field here.
Some sensitive data derived
from a GPS or whatever.
So one question
you might have is
what happens when we calculate
the length for this list.
Should the length of
the list be tainted?
It may strike you as
a bit counterintuitive
that the answer is probability
no, at least in the way
that TaintDroid and a
lot of these systems
define information flow.
So what does it mean to add
a node to the linked list.
It basically means three things.
So the first thing you do
is you allocate a new list
node to contain this new
data that you want to add.
Then the second thing you
do is you assign to the data
field of this new node.
And then the third
thing that you do
is you do some type of patch
up of the next pointers
to actually splice the
node into the list.
What's interesting is that
this step here doesn't actually
involve the data field at all.
Just looking at
these next values.
Right, so what's interesting
is that since only these data
objects are tainted, how we
calculate the length of a list.
We basically start
from some head node
and we traverse
these next pointers,
and we count how
many we traverse.
So that algorithm is not going
to touch the tainted data
at all.
So interestingly, even if
you have a linked list that's
filled with tainted
data, then just
calculating the
length of that list
won't actually result in
the generation of value
that is tainted at all.
So does that makes sense?
That may seem a little
bit counterintuitive,
and this is one of
the reasons why,
for example, like when we
were talking about the array,
for example.
They say array.length,
I'm not going
to generate any taint for that.
It's because of
reasons like this.
If you wanted a
stronger assurance
about-- not stronger assurance.
But if you actually
want to calculate
the length of the list to
generate a kind of value,
we could imagine that
your implementation, it's
a bit goofy, but you can
just decide to touch data
for no real semantic reason
other than to generate
taint in the resulting length.
Or, as I'll discuss towards
the end of the lecture,
you could actually
use a language
which allows you the
programmer to define
your own types of taint.
And then you can actually
define your own policies
for things like this.
One nice thing about TaintDroid
is that you as a developer,
you don't have to
label anything.
TaintDroid basically
does that for you.
It says here's all the sensitive
stuff that can be a source,
here's all the sensitive
stuff that can be a sink.
You as a developer,
you're ready to go.
But if you want that
pointer to be controlled,
you might have to build some
of the policies yourself.
All right, so in terms
of performance overhead
of TaintDroid, what
does that look like?
The overheads actually seem
to be pretty reasonable.
So there's going to be
memory overhead, and that's
the memory overhead,
essentially,
of storing all of
these taint tags.
And so there's going
to be CPU overhead,
and this is basically to
assign, propagate, and check
those taint calculations.
And that's because of
overhead like here.
So any interpreting
for the Dalvik VM,
we're actually doing
additional work.
So looking at the source,
looking at this 32 bit taint
information, we're
doing the or operations
that we discussed before,
and so on and so forth.
So that's
computational overhead.
These overheads actually
seem to be pretty moderate.
So for memory, the authors
report about 3% to 5%
in terms of the
extra RAM space you
need to store those taint tags.
So that's not too bad.
The CPU overhead is higher,
which I think makes sense.
They're both somewhere between,
let's say, 3% and about 29% CPU
overhead.
And the reason why I think it's
reasonable to see why that's
higher is because you can
imagine that every time you
step into the
interpreter loop, you're
having to look at these
tags and do some operations.
So even though it is all
these bitwise operations,
you have to do
that all the time.
So that seems like it's going to
get painful, whereas basically,
the overhead for this, OK, so
you put a couple extra integers
in memory somewhere.
That doesn't seem,
maybe, too bad.
Even on it's high end, 29%,
in of itself maybe that's OK,
because Silicon Valley
keeps telling us
that we need phones that have
like quad cores and whatnot,
so probably have a lot of
spare cycles sitting around.
So maybe that's not
all that crushing.
Although there might be a
problem with battery life.
So even if you have
these extra cores,
you might not want your phone
getting hot in your pocket
as you're just sitting
there, just sort
of churning and calculating
some of this stuff.
I think for here,
the main issue here
would be if this is
bad for your battery.
If it's not bad
for your battery,
then probably even at that high
end, that may not be that bad.
So that is essentially
an overview
of how TaintDroid works.
Any more questions before we--
AUDIENCE: Do you tag
something that also
has been there all the time?
Do you tag every
variable, or only
tag the ones that have this?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so you
basically tag everything.
So in theory, there's
nothing that prevents you
from not allocating any taint
information for stuff that
has no taint at all.
I think the problem,
then, with it--
then once something gains
even one bit of taint,
then you have to do dynamic
sort of layout changes.
So what if on the stack,
this local here, then it
had a taint, so now you're
allocating with this,
and it does get taint.
Or you have that extra
taint flag live on the heap,
and you're going to see
how it rewrites the stack,
and then someone made
your code-- so we're
going to see how that works.
So in practice, typical use
is like shadow memory somehow,
so every byte in the
application is backed up
by some byte of extra
information somewhere.
And in the case of TaintDroid,
that shadowing actually
lives alongside of the
actual variable itself.
Anyone has another question?
OK.
Cool.
This system essentially
tracks information
at the level of these high
level Dalvik VM instructions.
So one thing you might
think to yourself
is, could we track taint at
the level of x86 instructions
or the ARM instructions.
One reason why that
might be useful
is because then
we could actually
understand how information flows
through arbitrary applications,
not just ones that are running
inside this tricked out
VM that requires you to run
Java and so on and so forth.
So why not track
taint at that level.
It turns out that you
can, in fact, do that.
So there are projects that we
looked at at tracking taint
at this low level.
What's nice is that you maybe
get that increased coverage.
You don't throw a
line into [INAUDIBLE]
for how, for example, Java
code interacts with native code
methods.
It's all eventually
going to result down
to x86 instructions
executed, so that
removed a lot of the manual
effort that you as a developer
have to do to sort of understand
it's the taint semantics if you
use native methods.
But the problem with that, if
we track at this low level,
it can be very
expensive to do this.
You can also get a lot
of false positives.
So if they're spec'd
to the expense,
there's also this
issue of correctness.
As you may know, x86 is
an adversarially complex
instruction set.
There's all kinds of crazy
things that it can do.
I don't know if you've ever
seen an x86 instruction manual,
they're huge.
So they'll have one huge
manual that's this thick,
and then it'll say this is
instructions whose letters
start with M through P, and
there'll be this full on series
about that.
So it's actually
pretty tricky to think
about what it means to
actually track taint
at the level of x86 instruction.
Because even seemingly
simple instructions,
like sometimes at,
they're setting
all types of internal
processor registers
and flags and things like that.
So it's very difficult to
describe in the first place.
If you could do that, it's
also oftentimes very expensive.
You're sort of looking at things
at a very, very low level.
So the amount of state
you have to track
might get very
large very quickly.
It might be a very sensitive
computational clause.
Then there's this issue
of false positives.
This is actually
pretty devastating.
You can get into bad
problems if you ever
have kernel data that
improperly gets tainted.
And if this happens, maybe
because your infrastructure's
trying to be ultraconservative,
it doesn't want
to miss anything,
so it says well,
I'm going to err on
the side of security.
And I'm going to taint some
of this kernel data structure,
then what you get here is
this exciting term they
call taint explosion.
What this basically means
is that at a certain point,
there are certain things that
if they end up getting tainted,
they're involved in
so many calculations
that essentially everything
in your program gets polluted.
It's like one of these things
in Dungeons and Dragons
where you touch this
evil thing and eventually
death spreads
throughout your body.
This is very bad, because
if you can't tightly
constrain the way that taint
flows through the system,
then eventually what's
going to end up happening
is that you let this
run for a while,
the system's going to say
you can't do anything.
You can't send anything
over the network,
you can't display
anything on the screen,
because everything
in your system
seems like it's been tainted
by some sensitive error,
even if that's not the case.
One way that this can
happen is if somehow
the stack pointer or the
break pointer get tainted.
If this happens, you're
probably in a world of hurt.
You can imagine that all
of the instructions in x86,
for example, that access the
stack, they all go through ESB.
So the stack register gets
corrupted somehow, that's bad.
If the break point
register gets bad,
a lot of times when you want
your equivalents to access
local variables, it has
to go the EBP indirectly.
So if anybody ever touches
those in terms of taint,
it's basically game over.
So there's a link in
the lecture that's
about a paper that
acknowledges some of this stuff
and basically says that we have
to be very careful when we do
taint tracking at this low level
because very quickly, if you're
looking at how this works
in the Linux kernel,
there are certain optimizations
the Linux kernel would do
to make its code fast, but
will result, unintentionally,
in the break pointer or the
stack pointer getting tainted.
And once that happens, you
can't really do anything useful
with the taint tracking system.
AUDIENCE: So how do you do
this [INAUDIBLE] programs?
It seems like you have all
these register files in the CPU.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so great.
So all those register
files, it hangs back
to the correctness case.
So unless you are
very, very good
at understanding
x86 architecture,
there are going to be
things that you miss.
It terms of computation
level, how do you actually
do this thing.
There's this-- I think
the most popular way,
and I could be wrong about this.
So when I say it's
popular, the way I
know about, because I'm a
knowledge [INAUDIBLE], right.
There's this system
submitter called Bochs,
I think it's spelled like this.
They actually have
something called
TaintBochs, which actually does
x86 level innuation of flow.
And it's actually
an interpreter,
you can think of it as.
So it's going to take
your entire OS and all
your applications,
and it's going
to look at each x86
instruction and try to simulate
what the hardware would do.
So you can imagine this
is very, very slow.
What's nice about that is you
don't require any hardware
support, and then it's
relatively straightforward
to tweak your software
model of how things work,
if you discovered
that you weren't
tracking some registered
files or something like that.
AUDIENCE: So the ideal solution
would be architectural support.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so there have been
techniques to do that, too.
That gets a little bit
subtle because, for example,
if you look here
you've looked at how
we've allocated the taint
state next to the variables
themselves.
So if you bake in that
support in the hardware,
it can be very difficult to,
for example, change the way
you want the layout to work.
Because then it's like
baked into the silicon.
You could imagine doing some of
this because at a high level--
where do we have it.
So the Dalvik VM and TaintDroid
is executing these high level
instructions and it's
assigning taint at this level.
You can imagine doing that
at the hardware level, too.
So actually, if
this is the silicon,
you can probably make that work.
So that's definitely possible.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE: What
does TaintDroid do
with information built from
branching and permission tests.
PROFESSOR: Oh, we're going
to get to that in a second.
So just hold that thought,
we're going to get to that.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious,
how long was it
to things like buffer overflow
because all the things are so
nested together [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
So presumably, one would hope
that in a language like Java
there are no buffer
overflow, right.
But you can imagine
in a language like C,
for example, where you
didn't have this protection,
maybe there's something
catastrophic that could happen
or somehow, if you
did a buffer overflow
and then you were able
to overwrite taint tags
and you could set this to
zeros, then you could just
let your data exfiltrate.
AUDIENCE: I think if
it's super predictable,
like one every other one
for the next q variables,
there's no stacking--
PROFESSOR: I was going to
say, that's exactly right.
So you run into
somewhat similar issues
like what we can discuss
with the stack canaries,
because basically we have
this data on the stack,
like in this particular
layout, that you don't neither
want to make it
impossible to overwrite,
or if it is overwritten, one
that's hacked in some way.
So you're exactly
right about that.
So you can in fact do taint
tracking at this low level
although it may be expensive
and a little bit difficult
to get right.
So you might say well,
why don't we just punt
on this whole issue of taint
tracking in the first place
and instead we're just
going to look at the things
that the program tries to output
over the network, let's say,
and just do a scan for
data that seems sensitive.
That seems to be much
more lightweight,
you don't have to do this
dynamic instrumentation of all
the things the program's doing.
The problem with that,
though, is that that will only
work as a heuristic.
In fact, if the attacker knows
that this is what you're doing,
then it's pretty
easy to subvert that.
So if you're just
sitting there and you're
trying to do a grep for numbers,
Social Security numbers,
then the attacker can
just use base 64 encoding,
or do some other wacky
thing, compress it.
It's actually trivial to get
past that type of filter.
So in practice,
that's completely
insufficient from the
security perspective.
Now let's get back
to the question
that you brought up,
which was basically
how can we track flows
through things like branches,
for example.
So this is basically
going to lead us
to a topic that's
called implicit flows.
And so an implicit
flow occurs typically
when you have a
tainted value that's
going to affect the way that
another variable is assigned,
even though that implicit
flow variable doesn't directly
assign variables.
This will make more sense
with a concrete example.
Let's say that you have an if
statement that does something
like, it's going to
look at your INEI
and it's going to say
if it's greater than 42,
maybe I'm going
to assign 0 to x.
Otherwise I'm going to assign 1.
So what's interesting
here is that we're
looking at this
sensitive data here
and we're doing some
comparison of it up here,
but when we're assigning
to x down here,
we're not actually
assigning something
that is directly derived
from the sensitive data here.
This is an example of one
of these implicit flows.
Because the value
of x is actually
dependent on this thing
here, but the adversary,
if they're clever, can sort of
structure their code in a way
that there's no
direct assignment.
Now note that even here,
instead of just assigning to x,
you can just say let's
try to send something
over the network.
You might say over
the network x is 0,
or x is 1, or
something like that.
So that's an example of one
of these implicit flows that
a system like TaintDroid
cannot actually handle.
So do people sort of see the
problem here at a high level?
Yes.
This is called an
explicit flow as contrast
to those direct flows like
from the assignment operator.
AUDIENCE: What if [INAUDIBLE]
a native power function that
did exactly [INAUDIBLE]?
Because the output in
that case would be, right?
PROFESSOR: Well, let's see.
So it depends.
So if I understand your
question correctly,
you're saying there could
be some native function that
does something that's sort
of equivalent to this,
and so for example, TaintDroid
wouldn't know necessarily,
because it can't look
inside this native code
to see this type of thing.
The way that the authors
claim that they would handle
that is that they would say for
native methods that are defined
by the VM itself, they
would look at the contract
that method exposes
and they might
say things like I take
these two integers
and then return the average.
So then the TaintDroid
system would
say we trust that the native
function does that, so we
need to figure out what
the appropriate tainting
policy should be.
However, you are correct
that if something like this
was sort of hidden inside and
for whatever reason wasn't
exposed to the
public-facing contract,
then the manual policy that the
TaintDroid authors came up with
might not catch
this implicit flow.
It might actually
allow information
to leak out somehow.
But I mean for that
matter, there might even
be a direct flow in there that
the TaintDroid authors couldn't
see and you might still have
an even more direct leak.
AUDIENCE: So in practice, this
seems very dangerous, right?
Because you can literally send
the whole [INAUDIBLE] value
by just looking at
this last three--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
We had class a few times where
you'd sit in a while loop
and you'd try to construct
these implicit flows to do
these types of things.
There's actually
some ways that you
can think about trying to
fix some of this stuff.
At a high level,
one approach you
can do to try to
prevent this stuff
is you can actually assign
a taint tag to the PC.
Then essentially you taint
it with the branch test.
So the idea here is that we as
humans can look at this code
here and we can tell that
there's this implicit flow
here, because we know
that somehow to get here,
we had to look at
the sensitive data.
So what does that mean at
the implementation level?
That means that to
get here, there's
something about the PC that has
been tainted by sensitive data.
To say that we
have gotten here is
to say the PC has been
set to here or to here.
At a high level we could
imagine that the system would
do some analysis
and it would say
that at this point in the code,
the PC has no taint at all.
At this point, it gets
tainted somehow by the INEI,
and at this point here, it's
going to have that taint.
So what will end up happening
is that if x is a variable that
initially shows up with
no taint maybe we'll
say OK, at this
point, it's actually
going to give the taint of
the PC which is actually
going to taint it there.
So there's some sublety
here that I'm glossing over,
but at a high level that's
how you can capture some
of these flows here by
actually looking and seeing how
the PC is getting
set, and then trying
to propagate that to the
targets of these if statements.
Does that all makes sense?
OK.
And if you're interested
in learning more
about this, come talk to me,
there's been a lot of research
into this kind of stuff.
However, you can imagine that
the system I just described
may be too conservative
once again.
So imagine that instead
of having this code here,
this was also 0.
So in this dump case,
there's absolutely no reason
to taint x with anything
related to the INEI,
because you didn't actually
leak any information
in either of these branches.
But if you use it with a
naive PC tainting scheme,
then you might over-estimate
how much x has been tainted by.
So I should say there's
some subtlety you
can do to try to get around
some of these issues,
but it's a little bit tricky.
Does this all make sense?
All right.
AUDIENCE: Just a question.
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: When you get out of
the if statement, so you're out
of the branch, do you
[INAUDIBLE] taint out?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so typically, yes.
So like down here the PC
taint would be cleared.
So it would only be set inside
these branch things here.
And the reason for that
is because essentially,
by the time you
get down here, you
get down here regardless
of what the INEI was.
So yeah, you clear that.
It's a good question.
Let's see.
You talked about how you
might be able to taint
at this very low level, even
though that might be expensive,
one reason why it
might be useful
is because it will
actually allow
you to do things like see what
your data lifetimes look like.
So a couple lectures ago,
we talked about the fact
that a lot of times
key data, for example,
will live in memory longer
than you think that it should.
So you can imagine that even
if some of the x86 or ARM level
taint tracking is
expensive, you can imagine
using it to form an
audit of your system
and actually
tainting, let's say,
some secret key that
the user entered,
and just seeing where that
goes throughout your system.
It's an offline analysis,
it's not facing customers,
so it's OK for it to be slow.
That might actually really
help you to figure out oh,
this data's getting into
the keyboard buffer,
it's getting into the x server,
it's getting to wherever.
So even if it's slow, that can
still be very, very useful.
So I just wanted to
mention that briefly.
One interesting thing
you might think about
is the fact that as I
mentioned, TaintDroid
is nice because it constrains
the universe of taint sources
and taint sinks.
But as the developer,
maybe you want to actually
explicitly assert some more fine
grain control over the labels
that your program
interacts with.
So now as a programmer, you
want to be able to say something
like this.
So you query some int, and
let's say we call it x,
then you associate
some label with it.
Maybe the name of this
label is that Alice
is the owner of
this data, but Alice
permits Bob, or something
labeled with Bob,
to be able to see that.
TaintDroid doesn't let you do
this, because it essentially
controls that
universe of labels.
But maybe as a
programmer you want
to be able to do
a thing like this.
You can imagine that your
program has various input
channels and output
channels, and all
of these input and
output channels,
they all have labels, too.
And these are labels
that you as a programmer
get to actually pick, as
opposed to the system itself
trying to say here's this
group of fine set of things.
So maybe say for input channels,
you know the read values,
maybe they get the
label of the channel.
That's very similar to how
TaintDroid works right now.
So if you read
something from the GPS,
that read value is the
taint of the GPS channel,
but now you as a programmer can
choose what those labels are.
And then you could imagine that
for output channels that label
will channel has to match some
label value we've written.
You can imagine other
policies here as well.
But the basic idea is
that there are actually
program managers that
allow you the developer
to pick what the
labels are and what
the semantics for
those labels can be.
So what's nice
about some of these
is they do require the
programmer to do a little bit
more work, but the
outcome of that work
is that static checking--
and by static checking
I mean checking that's
done at compile time--
can catch many types of
information flow bugs.
So if you're diligent about
labeling all of your network
channels and screen channels
with the appropriate
permissions, and you're
very diligent about leaving
your data like this,
what can happen
is that at compile time,
when you compile your program
and your compiler can
tell you things like hey,
if you were to run this
program, then you actually
have an information leak that
this particular piece of data
will pass an equal channel,
which is untrusted.
And at a high level, the
reason why static checking
can catch a lot of these bugs
is because usually speaking,
when you think of some
of these annotations,
they're somewhat
similar to types.
So the same way that
compilers can catch errors
involving types and
installing type language,
you can imagine
that the compiler
in a language like this
can codes some calculus
over this label,
and in many cases,
determine hey, if you would
actually run this program,
this would be a problem.
So you really need to fix
the way that the labels work,
maybe you need to explicitly
declassify something,
so on and so forth.
AUDIENCE: You can't
just [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
yeah, that's right.
So depending on the
language, these labels
can associate people with IO
ports, all that kind of stuff.
That's exactly right.
So this is just
interesting to know about,
because TaintDroid has a very
nice general introduction
to this information flows
stuff, but there's actually
some really hardcore
systems out there
than can express
much richer semantics
in the control of a program with
respect to information flow.
And you know, too, that when
we talk about static checking
and being able to
catch many bugs,
it's actually preferable
to catch as many bugs using
static checking and
static failures as opposed
to dynamic checking
and dynamic failures.
There's a very subtle
but powerful reason
for why that is.
The reason is that,
let's say that we
defer all of the static
checks to the runtime, which
you could certainly do.
There's no reason you couldn't
take all the static checks
and give you a name for it.
The problem is that the failure
or success of these checks
is actually a covert
channel, perhaps.
So the attacker
could actually feed
your program some
information and then see
whether it crashed or not.
And if it crashed,
it might say, aha,
you've passed some dynamic
check of information flow, that
must mean something was
secret about this value I sort
of cajoled you into computing.
So you want to try
to make these checks
as static as possible to the
greatest possible extent.
If you want more information
on this kind of stuff, maybe
a good place to start,
a word to search is Jif.
It's a very
influential system that
built some of these issues
of label computation.
So you can start there
and sort of roll forward.
My co-professor actually
has done a lot of good work
on this, so you could
ask him about that
if you want to talk
more label stuff.
That's sort of interesting
to know that TaintDroid
is actually fairly restrictive
in the expressiveness
of the labels it
allows you to look at.
There are systems
out there that allow
you to do more powerful stuff.
Finally, what I'd like to talk
about is what we can do if we
want to track information
flows in some of these legacy
programs, or through programs
that are written in C or C++
that don't have all the
fancy runtime support.
So there's a very
cute system, some
of the same authors on this
paper that looks at this issue
of how can we track
informational leaks
in a system which we
don't want to modify
the application at all.
This is the TightLip system.
So the basic idea is
that they introduce
this notion of what they
call doppelganger processes.
TightLip uses doppelganger
processes evolved.
So the first thing it
does is it periodically
scans a user's
file system and it
looks for sensitive file types.
This might be things like your
mail file, your word processing
documents, so on and so forth.
So what it's going to do
for each one of these files
is it's going to produce
a scrubbed version.
So for example, if it
finds an email file,
it's going to replace the to
or the from information with,
let's say, a string of the same
length but just dummy data.
Maybe all spaces or
something like that.
It does this as a
background task.
Then the second thing it's going
to do, at some point a process
is going to start executing,
and so then TightLip
is going to detect when
and if the process tries
to access a sensitive file.
And if such an access
does take place,
TightLip is going to spawn
one of these doppelganger
processes.
And so what the
doppelganger process
looks like is very similar
to the original process that
tried to touch that
sensitive data,
but the key difference is
that the doppelganger, which
I'll abbreviate DG,
reads the scrubbed data.
So imagine that-- so the
process is executing,
it tries to access
your email file.
The system spawns this new
process, the doppelganger,
that doppelganger is exactly
the same as that original one,
but it is now reading from
the scrub data instead
of the real sensitive data.
What happens then.
Essentially,
TightLip, we're going
to run those two
processes in parallel.
It needs to just watch
them and see what they do.
And so in particular,
we're going to see,
do the processes issue
the same system calls
with the same arguments.
And if that's the case, then
presumably those system calls
do not depend on
the sensitive data.
So in other words, if
I start a process that
tries to open some
sensitive file,
I feed it basically junk
data, I let it execute.
If that doppelganger process
still does the same things
that the regular
process would have done,
then presumably it
wasn't influenced
by that sensitive data at all.
So essentially doppelganger
will let these processes run,
TightLip will let
these processes run,
and then check the
system calls here.
And then it might happen that in
some case the sys calls divert.
So in particular, what
if the doppelganger
starts doing things that the
regular version of the process
would not have done, and
then the doppelganger tries
to make a network call.
So just like in TaintDroid,
when that doppelganger tries
to make a network call,
that's when we say aha,
we should probably stop
what's happening right now
and then do something.
So if the system calls
diverge, then the doppelganger
makes a network call, then
we're going to do something.
So we're going to either
raise an alert to the user
or whatever.
Kind of like in TaintDroid,
but at this point
there's a specific
policy you can
add in some particular
system you're going to use.
But this is sort of an
interesting point at which you
can say well, somehow that
doppelganger process was
affected by that sensitive
data that was returned.
That means that maybe
if the user did not
think that a particular
process was going
to get exfiltrated data,
now the user can actually
do an audit of that
program to figure out
why that program returned send
that data over the network.
So does anyone-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So if you're
hitting something
like a word file or
whatever, you kind of
have to know what
you're zeroing out
and what you're [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good
question, that's right.
So I was going to
discuss some limitations,
and one of the limitations
is precisely that.
You need to have per
file type scrubbers.
So you can't just take
your email scrubber
and use it for Word.
And in fact, if those
scrubbers miss something,
so if they don't
redact everything,
then this system may not catch
all the possible sensitive data
leaks.
So you're exactly
right about that.
But I think-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So if
I understand, why
should the process look at the
data before saying go ahead?
Why wouldn't you just
send the stuff in?
PROFESSOR: Why
would the process--
AUDIENCE: If the process plans
to input data, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, no, no.
From the perspective
of the doppelganger,
I mean, it may try
to, in fact, look
and see things like does this
email address make sense,
for example, before it
tries to send it out.
But the doppelganger
process, it shouldn't
know that it's gotten
this weird scrubbed data.
So this gets back a
little bit to the question
we were just talking about.
If your scrubber
doesn't scrub things
in a semantically
reasonable way,
the doppelganger may, in
fact, crash, for example.
It expects things in this
sort of format, but it's not.
But at a high level,
the idea is that we're
trying to trick the doppelganger
into doing what it would do
normally, but on
data that's different
in the original version
and see if there
will be that divergence.
So one drawback is that,
like we're discussing,
this basically puts
the scrubbers in TCB
and if they don't work properly,
doppelgangers might crash,
you might not be able to
catch some violations, things
like that.
But the nice thing
about this is that it
works with legacy systems.
So we don't have
to change anything
about the application
itself runs.
We just have to make some fairly
minor changes to the OS kernel
to be able to track the
system call stuff, and then
things sort of work.
It's very, very nice.
And the overhead of the
system is essentially
the overhead of running an
additional process, which
is fairly low in a
modern operating system.
This is just sort of
a neat way to think
about how to do some type
of limited taint tracking
without doing heavyweight
changes to the runtime
without requiring changes
from the OS-- or sorry,
from the application.
AUDIENCE: Are we
only doing parallel
or waiting for each one?
Are we running both
processes and then
after that we can just
check that the system
calls are the same?
Like when do we check--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, two questions.
So as long as the doppelganger
process does things
that the OS can control and
keep on the local machine,
you can imagine running
the doppelganger process
and the regular one forward.
But as soon as the doppelganger
tries to affect external state,
so maybe the network
is doing this and that.
Maybe you can think of some
other linked sources like that.
Maybe there's
something like pipes,
for example, that the kernel
doesn't know how to create
doppelganger state for.
At that point you have to
stop it and then declare
success or victory, basically.
Any other questions?
All right, well, that's
the end of the lecture.
Have a good Thanksgiving.
See you next week.